I'm back because it's an emergency - Greta Gerwig
and Margot Robbie have both been overlooked in the nominations for the Oscars
this is the highest grossing film of the year that we're talking about
this is the film that the Oscars nominated for Best Picture
so I don't understand
I like call me crazy
I don't know
I don't understand how this works
but I would have thought
if something was good enough to be nominated for Best Picture
that the director would also be nominated because they directed the best picture
so I'm Doctor Zoe
I'm eating my lunch
I have a PhD in digital feminist activism
I make accessible
feminist content for people who wish to further their feminist identities
and I'm really angry
I'm really angry about this
because don't you think the Oscars
like the Academy
whatever they called
should be embarrassed
like embarrassed that they have so poetically
made the point that the Barbie movie was already trying to make
if you think of such a good point to make
why would you nominate the director who directed it
the actor who started at Margot Robbie
no no no you're just gonna go and nominate the man
as if to make the point that women are constantly overlooked
we have to work twice as hard to get the same recognition that men do
and our interest is sidelined consistently by the patriarchy
if that's the point you want to make
you've made it
but guess what
the film that you neglected to nominate properly already made it
so aren't you embarrassed
these people are supposed to have their finger on the pulse okay
well the pulse is saying that Barbie was a milestone movie
it was a milestone film
good films are made all the time
but Barbie is one of those films that will go down in history
was it an flawless academic execution of feminism as a whole no
but was it a very important cultural milestone that reappropriated
a doll that has often you know
been used as an idea to oppress us
revolutionise that idea and turn it in something that can empower us
and started so many important conversations
made feminism very accessible
and made a statement that we're here and we're fucking tired and we're over it
and it made all of these kind of feminist points very
very well flawlessly and an aesthetically pleasing way
it was a beautiful film
it was extremely well executed
it was funny and it was poignant
and it was a culturally important moment how how
can this be overlooked in this way
I do not understand
I do do they not know things like do they not understand what's happened
do they not understand what's happening in society right now
or do they understand it all too well and they're afraid of it
and they're afraid of us